hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to prison architect
okay we got a big problem going on here
we've got one person dead and then a
bullet waiting for Wallis and I don't
know what I'm gonna be able to do to fix
that I have a funny feeling this isn't
gonna end very happy considering a lot
of that's going on in here has not been
too terribly happy oh no good they
unlocked that finally I don't know how
we're gonna get power in here this is
gonna be nuts
the fire has already been put under oh
no the fire is not under control oh my
goodness oh my goodness oh my goodness I
did I thought that the fire was under
control
bring both fire engines please oh
there's no room for it okay we got to
get oh the hearse oh my god we gotta get
the horses out of here okay we need a
lot more workers if there's a little
work like this get in there get in there
get in there just get it done get it
done get it done we got stuff to do we
got things to work on we don't have time
to wait around all right we got that
done still a lot dying but we got to get
the fires in here so make this room make
one of them an infirmary be the top one
and then the bottom one will be the
morgue and I'm actually gonna separate
these out I'm gonna remove the doors and
we're gonna just gonna have we're just
gonna have normal doors because I don't
need those so we're gonna put those
later alright so got that okay so we're
gonna build floors get nice white tiles
and all this boink boink okay and then
for a morgue we need medical beds Boinky
Boinky Boinky Boinky boink and boink
okay and then we need morgue slabs slabs
it's a lovely way okay look at all the
slabs we can house so many slabs oh it's
like look at it it reminds me of those
RPG horror Maker games or RPG Maker
horror games that I played before you
know they're really really fun bizarre
ones okay so we need electricity going
through here cross here and cross there
and that should be enough to get
everything covered all right go go go we
got to go man I do not have enough
security staff oh let's give more more
guards more guards more guards more
guards court guard guard good good
guard guards guards guards okay man I
got all my workers working on cleaning
this up it looks like the fires are out
at least I think anyway yeah the fire is
under control so these guys can go away
I'm not that I had them in the area
anymore this crews pretty much dead so I
can send them away all right so we need
what happened is that I station police
in here I station police in there I
station police in there all right I
gotta get oh geez
yeah he's a one-man army go for it go
for it breath all right so we need
guards but not yet apparently well that
guy is a fighter oh geez
okay we need all of these guys in here
okay okay good they're all fixed up
that's good to go okay so that's good oh
no we're good
all right we're good benedict's calling
oh boy here we go I want my wheels now
Wallace is joining us and if I catch
sight of a tail you'll be scraping
pieces of him off the freeway oh thank
you for the lovely call always good
catching up that's it it's time to bring
this situation to an end the team is all
in position none of us are getting out
of here it's not you they want what are
you talking about I did it for money but
he did it for political gain the longer
the sentence is the more votes he got
who the [ __ ] you talking about
mayor Heller it was his blueprint i
justold the wheels oh that's not good
those files were the evidence that could
destroy his career you're [ __ ] me
oh boy oh this is not gonna end well
oh they're too happy about that what the
[ __ ] they're coming in get ready I
[ __ ] warned you oh geez Wow they shot
Wallace whoa
that wasn't that wasn't benedicted shop
Wallace that was the cops Wallace oh he
was my guide in this
were they intentionally going for him or
did they just shoot him because they
were trying to shoot Benedict I might
put my money on they intentionally shot
him they were told to hi Calvin Heller
too bad I saw that the facilities under
control and the rioters have been
subdued it could easily have turned out
a lot worse yeah much worse we've got
one hell of a cleanup operation ahead of
us I'd appreciate your help with that if
you got the time considering what I know
we don't have any building contractors
on site so the first step will be to
hire some new workmen to get the work
repairing the place I always thought
security here was much too lacs
these inmates have been given too much
free rein for too long that stops today
yeah I think it stops because of all the
dead bodies that have piled up I want
you to build us a new armory then deploy
armed guards at key positions around the
prison the sight of that will subdue
these prisoners and they'll think twice
about causing this much trouble again
I'm also approving the funds to provide
body armor to all the guards on site our
men need to be able to defend themselves
we've got a few other requirements there
are a lot of prisoners who need to be
taught the error of their ways build a
new solitary confinement wing I don't
like you I like Wallace I don't like
mayor Calvin hailer our guards will take
care of moving inmates to solitary as
required solitary confinement gives in
my it's time to reflect on what they've
done reminds them who is in charge
around here there's a lot to do here we
really appreciate your help once you
feel you've done enough and are ready to
move on click on the Polaroid by the
front gates oh my goodness I don't know
if I want to be a part of this what is
free fire mean Oh God turn that off
thank you very much
I think I'm gonna move on because this
is this is too much that's too much
whoa well I got a move on because holy
[ __ ] what the hell happened
conviction that could mean a few things
well Oh tattooed naked person oh not
quite naked okay
dr. Walter Hearst the lack of engagement
this facility is shocking men deprived
of every shred of humanity yeah I agree
they're being shown scant compassion or
respect oh it's the chief it's now with
these men deserve who are you to say
what these men deserve chief indeed
captain there's no way to treat a human
being they're deprived of every shred of
humanity why should they abide by our
rules
you can't expect them to respond in any
way but the utmost resentment we need
classrooms drug rehabilitation programs
a workshop so they can start to take
some pride in their skills you
misunderstand me doctor these men aren't
human see for yourself
see for yourself on your feet Morgan
Morgan Freeman Oh No
you've got a visitor I don't want to be
a part of this rehabilitation might as
well teach monkeys to play the banjo I
don't like this guy I think I'm supposed
to not not like him I think I like this
doctor man what's your name son
man ask you a question Henry sir
must be cold down there Henry put this
on lice in the bed sir eating me alive
shirt keeps out the rats biggest one
I've ever seen Oh God
whoa how are you sleeping
don't sleep only thing I do in ears
think lots of time for thinking what do
you think about dying mostly and my
little girl Oh she'll need you to be
strong Henry this will be hard for her
too and behind bars every sin every day
of her life she doesn't know I exist
oh it's never too late to change a life
Henry I'd like to come and see you again
if I may yes sir thank you sir oh man
call me Walter
can we do something about those rats
this isn't the third world I'll get some
rat poison in there well that seems no
it seems like a bad thing the guy thinks
about dying or they give him rat poison
or put rat poison in a Cell oh boy
hi doc how you doing following the
recent tragedy Dow Chemical Strait
prison we are under immense political
scrutiny until a permanent replacement
is found for the CEO position I'd like
you to take the reins there have been a
spate of suicides at this facility
recently and it's not hard to see why
but we have a more immediate problem the
powers that be have decided to send us a
huge batch of new inmates the first will
be arriving tomorrow and we don't have
anywhere to house them we need you to
build a brand new cellblock with enough
space to handle the new intake oh boy
all right can do oh it's even framed out
I've laid out the potential design for
the new cellblock here they should give
us a noose enough new sales to handle
the intake and the design includes its
own shower facility happy that a good
place for people to murder each other
apparently but it's up to you if you
choose to follow this design or
something totally different
my job is to prioritize the welfare of
these men get that new cellblock built
then we'll talk to how to achieve that
okay just leave that up here I want to
do the exact framework I am a hundred
percent down to clown with this okay
concrete wall oh let me speed this up a
little bit hurry up guys
hurry up please please please hurry up
please please please please okay I need
to put a door on the front there it's
gonna be the only entrance in and out
work faster please I don't know I don't
know what I need to do provide cell 440
inmates
oh so see it
okay so now that we got that and the
doors installed we can make rooms here
no we cannot I need to make this well
what is the sound of that
oh they're not done oh okay ah there we
go okay now I can do it
boink okay so now that I got that I'm a
simple guy I'm gonna follow this plan to
the tee and not deviate from it ever Oh
would it be easier just to do this and
cancel it probably all right now I'm
gonna build the yard and I'm gonna build
it right outside here so that it's
fenced in and they can get to it and
they will be able to get to it when I
build not all that but I'm gonna build
large jail doors on both of these they
can get right into the yard and have all
the fun times they need probably okay
but at least that's there that's good
the majority of this is here who [ __ ]
contraband found over there oh god he
got beaten to a bloody pulp
oh man the state of this prison is not
okay all right now I need to hook this
up to water and it would be pretty much
good
okay oh I need to put toilets and all of
them they need to go patty yeah it's
ready and apparently I forgot to build
walls here nope and Boop didn't want
people going through to anybody else's
room and now I need to get water to all
those [ __ ] okay and that should be
everything that we need for this and
then everyone is gonna be a-okay I
didn't put like TVs or bookshelves or
anything because we don't have that kind
of budget and we can't deal with that
but I need to put some stuff outside in
the yard so that they can all get their
exercise nice plenty of weights that's
all they get to do okay so I think we're
good we got cells for 30 peeps right
that's gonna be 30 maybe I need to bunk
bed these [ __ ] I have no idea
they're gonna be good enough can you get
that in there done yet please why does
there no power over there they're just
not enough power anywhere what is that
anyway why is there light there that
doesn't make any sense
that's [ __ ] provide a shower
facility I think this is a shower room
isn't it oh do I need to specify I
specify oh this is a shower okay and
then these are cells these are also
cells boink these are a hundred percent
probably cells these are also maybe
cells done was I'm not done all right
someone's gonna bunk bait well a bunk
bed bait bunk bunk debate someone's
gonna be masturbating in the bunk bed as
far as I know anyway they got cells
enough for everybody and clothes
surrounded by walls and doors what do
you mean it's not closed why is it not
enclosed it's surrounded by walls and
doors what are you talking about oh I
didn't see that let's fix that quickly
please please pretty please pretty
pretty please anybody anybody come in
and fix this please anybody anybody at
all nobody nobody wants to fix this
nobody nobody nobody here we go
is that gonna fix everything maybe not
enclosed surrounded by walls and or it
is enclosed quite obviously enclosed oh
I know what happened okay I know what
happened it was uh yeah the for some
reason these were sticking out on the
ends there I didn't mean to do that okay
so now we got everything
yes dr. Walter Hurst hello how's it
going
oh you're visiting the patient again I
was hoping to see you at one of my
sessions I can't do it I can't stay in
this hole any longer just take it a day
at a time I mean the whole stinking
place in here out there they won't let
me see my family I messed up sir and
that ain't about to change Henry it's
gonna be okay I'm right behind you it's
funny he said the exact same thing whoo
Henry you can tell me is it Wallace
this wasn't it Oh who's that that's not
Wallace he looked out for me uh-huh ever
since we were kids
uh-huh oh that don't look good
oh it's Benedict it's all connected keep
your [ __ ] together whatever happens kid
I'm right beside you
oh geez probably why this guy is being
unfairly treated
hey job Marty [ __ ] grab the money kid
okay got the money I got the money
forget the money in the car
let's just get their money oh that not
good well that definitely dates this
time they definitely 1950s looking [ __ ]
oh that ain't good drop your weapons now
probably maybe we'll probably still use
lethal force anyway oh gosh
well jeez oh [ __ ] shoot goddamn it
what the hell you waiting for shoot you
[ __ ] [ __ ] they look so cool behind
that car I guess oh geez not cool
anymore
not cool understand not cool oh it's not
cool [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] don't shoot don't
shoot oh man man so heavy I love the
story going through your though I love
the story oh and that was a picture that
was used before that was a picture
earlier in the game and oh man now it
shows why he got the shoulder injury
right beside me oh jeez
he ain't there no more I'll make you an
agreement come to my next group and I'll
see if we can relax your visitation
privileges you do that for me sir it's
not just for you Henry something's gonna
go wrong I have a feeling we've treated
these men like dirt for too long that
ends now the previous CEO was never a
big believer in prison or reform but the
way I see it we need to provide these
men with some sense of hope for the
future we need to give them the skills
they need to succeed when they're
released valuable trade skills a basic
education we should start a work at
Prentice ship scheme train these men
with some real-world skills so that they
have at least have a future they can
look forward to
I completely agree to that I'll actually
100% agree with that because there's a
lot of like there's a lot of this
culture that when you put when people
think of prisons they think of prisons
as like extremely harsh punishment which
of course should be when you do a
horrible crime you should be punished
for it but at the same time they shunt
them in the prison and then just lose
all hope for them and that's not the
society that hopefully will come about
in the future because there should be
some reform in terms of prison and like
oh I won't make too many grand sweeping
statements but it should just be a basic
thing that they're still human
like no matter what happens I understand
that crimes are horrendous in many cases
in each each case is individually
treated but at the end of the day the
majority of them should at least be
treated like humans because if they
don't treat others like humans and then
you don't treat them like humans how are
they ever gonna realize that there's a
life outside of the life that they've
chosen but anyway that's all say back to
the game there's a game I shouldn't take
this too seriously I shouldn't try to
save whatever is okay so anyway wow
that's a lot of stuff authorised prison
labor through bureaucracy okay so is
that in here it's in a program
behavioral therapy that'd be nice
pharmacological treatment spiritual
guidance
um prison Baraka see oh here whoa I
didn't even know this existed what the
hell is this alright
Wow lady then the cells in your prison
require a certain amount of space to fit
legal requirements but imagine how many
more cells you could fit in if that
wasn't the case
removes the minimum size requirement for
sander cells just our bed and nothing
else they can [ __ ] on the floor yeah
okay so we need wow this is a lot of
stuff okay we also need education for
that sign inmates to work in the kitchen
go to logistics and then prison labor
hmm kitchen safety and hygiene logistics
where's logistics okay now they're
showing me a bunch of stuff that I have
no idea okay let me just take this one
at a time ah a sign export zones near
the road I can do that export zones can
be done I'm going to assign that because
I know how to do that that is easy let's
do that
export zones right here okay so that's
that they're gonna do their thing assign
inmates to work in the workshop I don't
know where the workshop is Logistics
where the hell is logistics oh my god I
don't know where this is
oh [ __ ] this is whoa whoa whoa build a
workshop we need to build a workshop
okay so we need to build a workshop
first that's priority so let's do that
okay so we need a workshop okay so we're
gonna make this a workshop Bhavana
boobity boo boom and I don't know what
goes in a workshop but I'm gonna find
out assignment made to work in the
workshop so I'm assuming that a workshop
makes things like probably the optional
produce a hundred license plates which
would be nice because then we could get
some money from that can I build the
rest of that wall please thank you okay
so now that's gonna do that and I need
to fill it up with electrical power and
all the jazz that it needs bada bing
bada boom okay so that's there all right
we got that doors ready to go oh the
lights will come up as soon as that's
done they got the yard over there that
does not have power over there [ __ ] they
weren't able to watch TV because I'm an
a-hole and didn't provide the needs okay
so that's deer that's good okay so now
oh the room the workshop this workshop
is what do I do in the workshop there we
go workshop saw well that doesn't seem
dangerous that's really dangerous oh boy
all right you know what I don't know how
I feel about this but let's do it anyway
all right boink let's put that right up
against it now give a little space
workshop workshop workshop yeah okay
just load it up mmm workshop press boink
boink boink boink
I said boink why isn't it boinking okay
so we need to start workshop safety
induction right here so we need to do
that
no régime time slot I don't know how to
do that kitchen and safety hygiene also
we need to do that but we need to have a
meeting room there probably is a meeting
room around here isn't there oh I don't
know if there is
a visitation room over there but I don't
know if there's a meeting room there's
not a common area that's been
established so I got I think I got to
build another common area to be able to
do that because otherwise they're not
gonna be able to actually train them
unless they go to the office to do that
but I don't think that's how that's done
we need more janitors we need more Jan
and we have no janitors we need lots of
janitors army of janitors go my little
janitor school okay what the hell is
this little piece of [ __ ] bull clear
indoor area
oink can you yeah thank you that was in
the way I appreciate you working so hard
to make this easy on me yeah oh wow
disorderly whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa I
guess it's okay maybe everyone was on
the way to get food and got all flubber
nuked okay so we got that done we need
okay I can finally put into one more
thing that I need here workshop present
no not there not there not there not
there there we go okay now we need to
get people working on the thing but
first I'm gonna make bathing Stonier
because it looks weird without it okay
got that Oh
logistics there's logistics whoo okay
cool cool okay so I haven't trained them
yet ha but we're gonna get there all
right so this is gonna be common room so
common room in here bogeyed boink
we'll get power in there boy I get a
bank just like thusly
and then we'll just put a buttload of
chairs inside and everything is gonna be
hunky-dory I want you to boink at the
point okay so that should be good enough
but now I need to alright run training
and for pro programmer ever you will
need to assign two hours of work time in
the regime schedule screen otherwise
prisoners will not have time to attend
the training programs okay so the
regime's schedule is right over
regime okay there we go so free in free
time no not lock up what no not lock up
ah free time their work time okay so
work time 8:00 a.m. this will be work
time okay they have free time in the
evening but for this time they need to
do oh they only get six hours of sleep
at night well that sucks for them oh
well so we got meeting rooms I can also
since I got a meeting rooms that can
have the carpentry apprenticeship
general education qualification
Foundation education Berger behavioral
therapy we're gonna get all the stiff
pharmacological treatment of jigs jokes
alcoholic groups Anonymous parole
hearing spirits who got nah now we're
not gonna do it we're not gonna do that
here we're not gonna do this either all
rooms staff only knew no room found okay
not that okay not that all right oh yeah
these good enough it's good enough for
me and it's good enough for everybody so
we got that all right we're making
progress it was actually more of a
technical episode but we're making a lot
of progress I just want to see if this
works properly and then we'll be able to
come on man you're making it bad for
everybody around here do I have an
infirmary I don't even think this place
has an infirmary does it god damn it
this prison is just nothing it'd be
nothing without me nothing at all what
I'm gonna do is I'm just gonna make this
into all so that it's the infirmary well
geez all these people need to be
infirmed oh my god yeah I had no idea
who is that Dyer holy [ __ ] alright so
just medical beds is all we really need
in there right I suppose I could have
fit more I didn't know that it was that
dire okay now we need doctors point
point point puppet debate development
get four of them whoa shoot him up sure
don't put the healing juices whoa what
is that whoa oh well that's no good
what is that there's a Polaroid there
whoa
oh I didn't know that was a secret that
you could find around here I had no idea
okay so I believe everything is in place
there are a lot of people in the holding
cells why are there so many people oh
because I haven't built enough beds for
everybody oh my god the prison is not
big enough for this I can't handle this
oh geez we can't handle this but either
way oh wow 127 251 that's pretty bad oh
we need to start putting bunk beds in
this [ __ ] oh my god but either way that
is all the time after this episode I'm
gonna carry on in the next episode on
another day so thank you everybody so
much for watching and as always I will
see you in the next video